[Music]  mr. Perlmutter I can show you around  that'd be great thank you so what do you  do around here read books  transcribed music swim at the river go  out at night sounds fun  alright later intimated quitter that  underscores I'll just watch this is how  I say goodbye to us and the time comes  later meanwhile we'll have to put up  with him for six long weeks muscles are  firm not a straight body in these  statues they're all curved sometimes  impossibly Curt and so nonchalant hence  their ageless ambiguity as if they're  daring you to desire them Oh Josie  without my eyes is there anything you  don't know Wow  I only knew how little I know about the  things that matter what things that  matter you know what things saying what  I think you're saying  shouldn't said anything yeah just  pretend you never did  [Music]  tell me by your name and I'll call you  back  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  you